I want to tell you about the most
powerful sales tactic that I have
learned and I never learned it from a
book I actually learned it by accident
we had like 100 new customers are
supposed to come in and I ran out of one
of the key products I had ladies come in
the first half of the day and able to
get the products and then some of their
friends who signed up with them came in
the second half today and we're like hey
my friend Sandy told me that I need X X
Y and Z and I was like oh we don't have
Z anymore and so rather than me try and
skirt around like this clear item that
was on the list I said hey by the way
you can get this one for cheaper down
the street at Costco after I made that
one crossout I was like but you do want
this and this from us and they're like
okay cool as soon as I made that switch
from saying hey you don't need to buy
this one you can get that from over
there everyone bought what I recommended
afterwards if you believe in the stuff
that you sell you can create an
environment where someone will trust you
faster by giving them a reason to trust
you that you acted in their
self-interest rather than your own so
that they can feel like you're not
trying to take advantage of them